or satellite provider welcome everyone
my name is Cynthia Smoot I am work at
Fox 13 in Tampa that's WTVT in the tampa
television market I do the five o'clock
at eleven o'clock news and today not
only do I get to talk to a really great
author about her new book Ray and Joan
and author of Radio shangri-la but Lisa
Napoli and I go way back to the 80s when
we worked together at a TV station in
North Carolina so we are reconnecting
now with me asking the questions of her
which might make her slightly nervous
except I know that she knows the answer
to every single question that I am going
to ask her today because she researched
this book for five years welcome Lisa
thank you so much thank you for being
here with me oh we're so happy to have
you and her first book some of you may
have read it was radio shangri-la all
about the kingdom of Bhutan which I love
the fact that they have don't have a GNP
but they have a it's a G and H I guess
most national happiness Cup national
happiness so we are happy that we're
here today to talk about your new book
which is ray and Joan and when we say
ray and Joan we mean Ray Kroc and his
third and final wife Joan Kroc his widow
and the story is so compelling in so
many ways Lisa but I think we need to go
back to the beginning a little bit here
because McDonald's of course is huge
it's ubiquitous it's everywhere but it
had some really modest beginnings in a
little town in California with a couple
of brothers so when you started
researching that took you where it took
me to San Bernardino California which is
a small ish time it was really small
back then and yes it was two brothers
who came from New Hampshire to get not
only out of the weather in New Hampshire
to California in the 20s but they wanted
to make their way in the movie industry
like a lot of people did and still do
today but back then the early days in
the talkies dick and Mac McDonald made
their way west and they found out very
quickly as many people do that it's hard
to make it in the movie in
industry so they wound up starting an
orange juice and hotdog stand and that
orange juice and hotdog stand
led them to open a rib restaurant and
then they decided that they were having
a hard time if anybody remembers the era
of car hops the car hops were unreliable
they didn't show up for work they they
would serve you to your car this is at a
time in America when people were just
falling in love with the car suburbs
were being built roads were being built
for the first time and the brothers just
had a hard time employing dishwashers
and car hops who attracted boys which
meant shenanigans and the parking lots
glasses got broken so it was it was a
pricey proposition and the ribs were
very hard to make so they shut down and
decided to pare down their menu to just
about ten items and that included
hamburgers and milkshakes and french
fries they had a very terrific formula
for making the French fries and at first
people in San Bernardino where they had
moved their restaurant were very upset
because they liked this carhop service
but it didn't take very long before
people fell in love with the expeditious
service the speedy service they called
it and the good food and it was cheap
food too is fifteen cents a hamburger so
you could have a whole meal for
forty-five cents with a shake and fries
so yeah that that's where McDonald's
really began in the desert of California
and they were the McDonald brothers
right dick and man Mac yep Big Mac maybe
ironically no it's too bad yeah okay so
that was the very beginnings and it
became quite popular they became sort of
wealthy for that day didn't it yeah they
were working as hard as anybody who
works in the restaurant business ever
does which is very they each split the
shift they work till 11 o'clock at night
they felt really really lucky because
they were able to buy new Cadillac's
every year that was their idea of
success they were able to upgrade their
Cadillac every
neither one was married neither had kids
they live together in a house they
bought up on a hill and they were just
happy they worked hard but they were
happy with what they were making about
$100,000 a year profits and it was life
was good and that in the early 50s that
was a lot of money lots of money so they
were obviously doing something right and
then other people started becoming
interesting so they did do some
franchising of sorts didn't they they
found so a trade magazine wrote about
this speedy system that they had and
basically they put the hamburger on the
assembly line they figured out a way in
a very small space to move the
production of food very quickly out to
you the customer is fast and I think it
was in under 10 seconds if you placed an
order it was really really quick and so
putting the hamburger on the assembly
line was great and other people all
across America were opening these
hamburger stands looking to be
entrepreneurial small businesspeople
small businessmen usually and so San
Bernardino became Mecca people would
flock there and stand outside and I left
out an important detail which is that
this first McDonald's was in glass in
glass so you could see in the restaurant
which now you know we see it all the
time but then was revolutionary so what
was so exciting was all these people
would show up and want to steal the idea
for this McDonald's and they sketched
and dick and Max saw these people
sketching and they realized well we
could probably sell this formula so they
did they put it in a manual and they
sold the idea and they didn't even
really want to sell the name to them
that was didn't make any sense why would
you want to use McDonald's on your
restaurant but they they did people did
and for nine hundred and fifty dollar
fee you got to buy the blueprints for
McDonald's which included these golden
arches which eventually as we know
became ubiquitous what a bargain not a
bargain now that we look back on it now
in 2016 so that was the beginnings of it
then and so now you had other McDonald's
starting to pop up in various places but
they were really more interested in just
what they were doing right there and San
Bernardino
happy doing what they were doing yeah
they had other offers from people who
wanted to take the idea national but
they were pragmatic they knew how hard
they were working on this one restaurant
but they didn't want to invest the time
and energy and going state to States and
slogging around they were doing just
fine
okay so geographically now let's move
over to the Midwest and let's talk about
a man named Ray Kroc who was doing his
own thing at the time but was pretty
much an entrepreneur really mmm-hmm hard
charging sales guy and now you're gonna
bring him into the picture for us and
give us a little idea about who was Ray
Kroc Ray Kroc was sort of a
hail-fellow-well-met
old guard salesman he had been selling
paper cups since he was a young man he
then in that work found the multi mixer
this multi spindle milkshake mist
machine mixer that allowed you to do six
at a time five and six and five at a
time
which was revolutionary technology just
as the paper cup was when the paper cup
was invented and he just loved being on
the road
he loved the the the ethos of the sale
he liked to figure out what it was that
made you want what he was selling and he
was just a larger-than-life personality
yeah and so with this milkshake machine
that's how he encountered the brothers
so he's out selling his milk his
milkshake machine and he happens to go
he hears about this McDonald's operation
out in California so he goes there and
what do you think happened when Ray Kroc
met the McDonald's brothers for me you
know
well the McDonald's brothers knew him is
mister Multi mixer because they bought
multi mixers and they bought many multi
mixers and Ray's was intrigued by why
would one little store need so many of
these multi machine multi mixer machine
and it's a mouthful uh you would think
by now I'd be able to say it and so he
went there to say hello they were happy
to meet him because you know he sold
them a very important piece of equipment
that helped their business they could
Bank milkshakes until you came up and
needed a vanilla it was
right away so that was very helpful to
their system and they met ray and Ray
was dazzled he describes it in his
autobiography it was almost as if he's
describing falling in love because the
system was so perfect to him he'd seen a
lot of stores a lot of drugstore
counters a lot of restaurants and this
system was so beautiful he also really
fell in love with that not just the
efficiency but the cleanliness he was a
neat freak and so he he was very happy
to see this and he wanted to figure out
how to propagate it across the land
because in his mind the more McDonald's
the more multi spindle milkshake
machines there would be sold so really
it started with milkshakes for him it
really did so he he meets the McDonald
brothers and he sells them all these
milkshake machines and what point did he
decide this needs to go big and how do I
make this go big when he first laid eyes
on the McDonald's operation all those
other people were there sketching and
trying to figure out how to rip off the
idea or more politely emulate it mimic
it but but Ray decided he didn't want to
steal it he wanted to help sell it and
so he that night went for dinner with
them and said please let me franchise
and they were reluctant they had as you
say they've begun franchising they had a
franchise agent who was working on their
behalf who was ill who became ill not
long after ray entered the picture and
so the stars aligned and basically they
said you know what yeah if you want to
do it no skin off our back go ahead and
do it so he started doing it he started
franchising it and that led him his
first franchise opening was in Des
Plaines Illinois not far from where he
lived in Chicago and that of course I
believe is the McDonald's that if you go
to McDonald's corporate they consider
that the first opening of a McDonald's
in the United States yeah and it's it
looks like a museum you can't there is
an actual McDonald's functioning across
the parking lot but there is it looks
just like it did in the old days thank
paying homage to the original and that
would be the original Ray Kroc store
right so was he successful then after
that was he opening them in various
places he was he he wasn't opening them
as quickly as you might think but part
that is because other people were
opening opening their own hamburger
stands without buying into the franchise
but hee hee it was hard it's hard to
sell something like that hard to sell
the formula but he was doing ok and he
was a couple of years in when he went to
st. Paul Minnesota which is where our
story takes a turn for the romantic okay
so now now we start to get into the Ray
and Joan part here okay so let's back up
just a little bit and tell us a little
bit about who Joan is before she met Ray
Kroc on that fateful evening yes so Joan
was 26 years younger than Ray so ray was
52 at that point so Joan was in her 20s
she was a young mother she was a
beautiful blonde woman and she was a
very very skilled pianist and organist
and back in the day that was a very
valued profession people would play in
restaurants which she did she played on
television local television she was so
beautiful that the local TV owner hired
her to play music in the breaks in
between shows because of course that was
before videotape right and she also had
a really good concern going selling I'm
sorry selling lessons music lessons to
kids so she was really working very hard
with these three jobs but the job she
loved was at the Criterion restaurant in
st. Paul Minnesota where she would play
the organ or piano and actually she
played the organ in the dining room she
was apparently up on a pedestal and
entertained the diners and then after
dinner hours she would go to the lounge
where she played piano okay so now take
us back to that evening and now keep in
mind Ray's married he has a child at
home yes at least Wow she's out of the
house but yeah she's gone okay then then
Joan is married with a child at home I
believe okay so now she's doing her
thing at the criterion right pulling the
piano and Ray walks in Ray had been
selling for about two years this is in
1957 and he walked in
was there to sell mr. Jim Dean the owner
of this restaurant a franchise he'd
asked him to come
Jim's I never bought the milkshake
machine mixer because he had an elegant
lobster restaurant he didn't really need
a milkshake machine but he knew ray
because of that and he invited ray ray
came in for dinner to have a dinner
meeting and sure enough he was waylaid
by this beautiful woman playing the
organ and not only was he attracted to
her youthful good looks but he himself
was a pianist he had made money as a
pianist early on in his life and loved
playing piano so he was taken by not
just her looks but her technical musical
proficiency so that was a very
intoxicating thing for him now that
meeting did they actually meet that
night I mean did they did he get
introduced or how did that happen the
best I can tell from talking with people
and also from what ray says in his
autobiography which of course with
anybody's autobiography you take a
couple of grains of salt he at he
demanded to meet her and yeah he went
over and said hello but the extent of
the conversation was has never been
completely clear even Joan's daughter
hasn't she was there that night too
her father came with her to pick Joan up
to take her home after work but it's not
entirely clear the depth of the
conversation but what happens next sort
of suggests that there might have been
more to it than just this quick
interaction which is that Joan's boss
Jim bought a franchise he opens store
number 93 in st. Louis Park Minnesota
and he hired Joan's husband to manage it
oh wow okay so there's a spark that
night but it's gonna still be a while
before it's officially ready Joan
correct right even though their lives
from then on may have been on separate
but paths but that continue to connect
in ways right so give us an idea then of
what happened after that well it's
really important to point out that in
1957 and for several years forward
McDonald's was not successful for the
corporation for
the people who opened franchises it was
very lucrative and they were paying a
1.9 percent royalty to the McDonald's
Corporation of which half a percent was
going to the McDonald's brothers and
that wasn't enough to keep the
corporation growing at the rate that it
needed to and helping corporate police
the standards from store to store so Ray
was under a lot of pressure because he
was growing the company and he was
hiring people who were very helpful to
him in fact in several cases they were
enormous ly helpful they helped save the
business but it was it was a difficult
time because other people were starting
to franchise to McDonald's had not
invented franchising they just came up
with a very particular formula that
really really worked for them but what's
interesting is that the stores were
doing great and McDonald's was becoming
a nationally known brand they were
investing in advertising local operators
like Jim Zion and in Minnesota really
understood the power of advertising but
the corporation was on a perilous slope
to bankruptcy so it's so crazy so with
that in consideration then what happens
then to sort of get the relationship now
between Joan and Ray who obviously felt
something that night back in books of
1950s at 57 but it would be several more
years before they actually got married
so we need to fill in the gap here
between what happened between that night
and when they finally actually did get
married so Joan's husband was so good at
managing this McDonald's in st. Louis
Park Minnesota that he got a large bonus
a $10,000 bonus which was you know an
incredible sum of money and he took that
money and plowed it back into his own
McDonalds and at that time people and
we'll get to this as it relates to this
beautiful place where we are right now
at that time to open a McDonald's it's
sort of like the news business you had
to go where the opportunity was and Joan
and her husband
we're told they had two choices of where
to go if they wanted to open their own
franchise and one was in Allentown
Pennsylvania
and the other was in Rapid City South
Dakota and because Raleigh wasn't
originally from that part of the world
they chose Rapid City South Dakota so
off Joan and Raleigh and their young
daughter moved to Rapid City with
extremely little money in their pockets
and just grand ambitions that if they
were able to open this McDonald's then
maybe their family finances would be on
better footing themselves and that's
exactly what they did so Joan at that
point women were not allowed to work in
McDonald's that was part of an edict
from the McDonald's brother McDonald
brothers not just ray
but what wives were expected to help
their husbands and so Joan when they got
to Rapid City oversaw the construction
of the set of golden arches on Main
Street and started ordering the stock
because all the food came locally it was
all sourced locally it wasn't hauled in
on a truck because Ray was very
committed to keeping the food local and
the standards that that meant that could
be kept up so we have life in South
Dakota now where Joan is working behind
the scenes and is probably doing a lot
of really important things that at the
time you know a lot of women did that
and maybe just didn't get all the credit
for but right she clearly had some sense
for business correct yes oh yes she was
very shrewd and not afraid so how do
they cross paths again take us now to
the point where because I believe there
was Ray Kroc was married three times
so there's another wife between when he
and gentlemen finally get married and
I'm sure that that's got its own level
of entry so kind of give us an idea of
how what happens they diverge again
before they eventually come together
well what's interesting is at that
moment in time in the 60s they were both
very committed to McDonald's from
different perspectives Joan through her
husband Raleigh and the franchise and
then several other stores that they
opened in Rapid City and then ray of
course building this huge company with
it's important to point out a man named
Harry sonim born who was key and
critical and coming up with the formula
that helped McDonald's actually get on
good sound footing which was to own the
underlying real estate of the McDonald's
and he he was the real business minded
person who is going into different
communities and helping convince people
who own the land and it's hard for us to
imagine just how blank the landscape was
then because of truth and different than
it is now so these are people who had
parcels of land and places where there
was very little else going on and so
Harry went in and helped negotiate bank
loans and broker deals with real estate
owners and built these McDonald's and
Rey was much more the hamburger guy
whereas Harry was much more of the the
high-minded finance guy so that's going
on while Jones helping her husband but
they continue to somehow be involved
with each other and I'm pretty sure it
has something to do with one of rays
early hires who was a world war two
pilot who owned a little Cessna and Ray
and Harry and June Martino who was early
on very integral in super integral she's
a whole other book she's ended up living
in Florida when well I won't go too hard
for it we asked about yeah okay the
early the early McDonald's core team
would fly around the country in the
Cessna and look overhead for the
churches and the schools and identify
parcels of land but somewhere along the
way ray was stopping off in Rapid City
and Joan was seeing him somewhere okay
somewhere and so a relationship and
evolved he was desperate to marry her
she almost married him in 1961 she
didn't he married someone else he
divorced his first wife married someone
else not to give away the entire story
but in 1965 when McDonald's went public
and ray became enormously wealthy as did
some of the people closest to him that
was when he was married to his second
wife so Joan was still in Rapid City
when ray hit life's lotto during the IPO
of McDonald's and became instantly worth
something like thirty three million
dollars on paper okay which is huge and
that
is really huge so we're gonna go ahead
and race forward then you'll have to
read the book to get up to from 1965 to
1969 which is a critical year because
that is the year that they finally get
married
breath yes Joe what kind of wedding was
it I mean now they're both divorced
right and did they have the big wedding
or was it a little small thing or no
it's very quick and it was small and it
was at the J and R double arch ranch
which was a spectacular ranch property
that ray bought right after he struck it
rich in 1965 in part because all of a
sudden he was extremely wealthy and this
was a beautiful piece of property but
also because that was where he
headquartered what was known what became
known as the Kroc foundation so it was
both a little bit of a rumpus room for
McDonald's folks but it was also a
retreat for ray and Jayne his second
wife but when he divorced Jayne his
second wife in order to marry Joan it
was very convenient that the place was
called the jnr double arch ranch yeah
California right in California okay in
the Central Coast if anyone's seen
sideways or been to the Central Coast of
California it's sort of a closer to LA
version of Napa and Sonoma Valley it's
quite beautiful it wasn't wine country
than it was cattle country and ray
excuse me and his second wife lived in
Beverly Hills so it wasn't easy you know
weekend really yeah for the weekend so
now so they get married in 1969 he
finally marries this woman that you know
he has been interested in for four years
and was it as idyllic as perhaps they
both thought it would be having waited
so long it was for ray because ray now
felt that he was complete he had
everything you know McDonald's had done
well beyond his wildest imagination he
was a celebrated businessman at a time
you know now we have celebrity CEOs and
it's their dime-a-dozen they're still
interesting but back then that a CEO
would be so media savvy and friendly was
very unusual and he was a perfect
Horatio Alger story you know milkshake
machine salesman become
multi-multi-millionaire with selling
hamburgers you know it was just a
fantastic story because there were a lot
of people who are very dubious about
this business sustaining you know it
didn't seem to make any sense now it
seems again so obvious to us but back in
the 60s Wall Street in particular was
extremely dismissive of this idea until
of course the stock went public and kept
going crazy as over the years but he was
extremely happy ray was and they landed
in Chicago which is where he had started
his well where he'd lived his whole life
but Joan quickly discovered that Ray was
a difficult and tempestuous person which
she may have been aware of over the
years but she recognized that Ray had a
serious problem with drinking and it was
only two years after they married that
she threatened or did file for divorce
and then almost as as quickly as she
filed for divorce she very mysteriously
decided to stay in the marriage and
that's where her core sense of
philanthropy really began because
instead of staying in the marriage and
just being what she could have been
which was the much younger spouse of
this extremely wealthy man and spending
money on all kinds of baubles she
decided to start a charity which she
called Operation cork which was Kroc
spelled backwards and operation corks
mandate was to help families of people
who drank and this again was at a time
when people didn't talk about this sort
of thing very often Betty Ford hadn't
even come out and even on there wasn't
even on the map so the fact that Joan
was so moved by her experiences with
al-anon which some may know is the sort
of core companion to AAA which of course
helps people who do drink that had been
around and that was enormous ly
successful but in the 70s there were a
number of people who were working to
figure out ways to morph AAA for other
purposes as
well as to address the larger issues
which is how the family was impacted and
Joan was front and center at that she
used a slice of the money that Ray had
earmarked for charity at the Kroc
Foundation and she would convene people
at the spectacular ranch where she had
married ray in 1969 and just brought
together the great minds who were
thinking about that and who were eager
to figure out ways to develop these new
systems but what I love is that she
didn't just do that which would have
been terrific enough she was very active
in creating media so all these years
she'd seen McDonald's grow and grow
thanks to the use of mass media as we
all know they were terrific they are
terrific merchandisers today that's
nothing new that was dating back to the
very earliest days of the business and
Joan borrowed that for her work with
alcoholism addiction and made movies she
produced a play she produced a series of
public service announcements using the
best animator at the time in the country
she published books and she got Dear
Abby or with the help of the PR people
from McDonald's she got Dear Abby to
write about a pamphlet that she
published and they were deluged with
requests so it was clear that they
touched a nerve and it's just so
exciting that this woman with a high
school education was able to do such
formidable work what did ray think about
that study enough ray while he didn't
seem to think that he had a problem with
drinking he loved what Joan was doing
the people around ray the closest
McDonald's advisers were nervous because
they didn't want Joan talking about ray
most of them didn't believe that Ray had
an issue this was a time when the idea
that somebody who was super successful
had any sort of problem was unthinkable
now we you know hear about it in the
news so much there's nothing unusual and
rarely is it even untoward that someone
has an addiction problem they go they
get it taken care of they come back and
usually often things are okay but in the
70s that was just not something
was even fathomable so ray was cool with
it and in fact ray would hang out at the
ranch when these meetings occurred with
all these diction ologists they were
called which is a quaint term from back
then and they come and they meet and ray
would be there and his robe smoking a
cigarette and having a cocktail and just
chiming in in a conversation and he was
concerned and he was happy for her he
was concerned about the bigger issue
there's a whole chapter in in the book
about their relationship with Dartmouth
that has a little bit to do with
Dartmouth's competing wish to get money
from Ray for the business school and
Joan swoops in and manages to reroute it
for the meta medical program that was
extremely important in in the addiction
movement and actually continued until
very recently so yeah what was their
life like together so she has this going
on and she's very passionate about it
and he's supporting her it sounds like
so and he's obviously growing this
Empire and she's doing this but what was
their life like together can give us an
idea of what it was like it was larger
than life like both of their
personalities they had crazy crazy sums
of money that they used the way people
who are enormous ly rich do and sure
they bought incredible real estate she
had incredible baubles at one point ray
bought a baseball team just because he
heard that the San Diego Padres were in
trouble and he sort of swooped in and
plunked down ten million dollars to buy
the baseball team but it was very
tempestuous and people who knew them
well and were around them often were put
in the uncomfortable position of
refereeing between the two of them
because they weren't the kind of couple
who would steam quietly through dinner
and then go home and have the fight they
would have the fight right there so
there was you know no boundaries with
them there were no boundaries with them
and Liz and I'm sorry Joan's daughter
described them as Liz Taylor and dick
Burton they were just very tempestuous
and volatile it was the
cults it was difficult and yet it had
this veneer of glamour because you know
they were running around in Chicago in
the 70s as the toast of the town and
then ultimately in San Diego when they
moved there because of the team and I'm
thinking they probably ran with some
pretty famous people at that time too so
who was some of the the company they
kept well they were able to have Tony
Bennett come to a party that you know
any party that they had they would like
to invite Tony to come play piano
because why not you know their interests
themselves and the plane get him setting
the plane and the plane really did ferry
both the dot that she was a huge animal
lover so the plane would often ferry
dogs places that they needed to go for
vet appointments they they baseball
players were a big part of their life
once ray bought in to the team
Joan really became friendly with some
extremely formidable men after ray died
like mr. Rogers was a very close friend
of hers Fred Rogers father Ted Hesburgh
of Notre Dame Mercedes McCambridge the
actress but yeah they they had they
lived this you know larger than life
very gilded life their apartment on
Lakeshore Drive in Chicago was
apparently extremely opulent and the
first thing they did when they
redesigned it was to make sure that
there was an organ built into the wall
and then of course there was a piano too
so they they were very big into parties
and glamorous parties so we want to talk
a little bit about more Joan and her
philanthropy and I want to leave time
for questions too so
Ray Kroc died in 84 in 84 and he leaves
behind how much money about five hundred
million dollars
five hundred million dollars so that's
half a billion dollars yes and in the in
that day and age that would be the
equivalent of say what today at least
three four times that yeah somebody's
told me and I can't remember but it's a
lot a lot it's a lot of money but even I
have
is living that lifestyle he passes away
and at what point did we know that she
was going to turn into the
philanthropist that she did become was
it right away or did it take a while or
did it just sort of unfold we got it
stirring if there was a stirring with
the operation cork and then as Rey it
was in his last years Joan exerted her
power over the Kroc Foundation which Ray
had hired his brother to run his brother
was a research scientist completely
different than Rey except that he was
fastidious also but he was a research
scientist and he'd been giving money
away with the Kroc foundation to very
highfalutin science medical research
that was not distinguishable for most
mere mortals it was he was convening
scientists from all around the world
around very very highfalutin subjects
and Joan was kind of annoyed by that and
Joan especially during this Dartmouth
period where there was this push and
pull to get them to give big donations
to the school which by the way they had
nothing to do with but that's a whole
other story you'll have to read in the
book if you're interested they she just
seemed very interested in the idea of
philanthropy and it was when he died
almost immediately the money was
transferred right before he died into
the Joan B Kroc Foundation and literally
the week that he passed away in early
Jan in earth in January 1984 she was
making donations to local charities in
San Diego it really took a turn and what
made me really fall in love with Joan
was in July of 84 you may remember that
a man walked into McDonald's in San
Ysidro not far from where ray and Joan
had been living in La Jolla California
in the San Diego area and it was the
worst mass murder
our history at that time that time um
and Joan viscerally and immediately
stepped forward
she was the largest single shareholder
in McDonald's at that point at Ray's
death and she stepped forward and
pledged $100,000 of her own money to
start a Victims Fund and had a news
conference didn't call McDonald's didn't
didn't talk to anybody just came forward
and she wasn't a public person if you
were in the addiction movement you might
have known about her because of this
work that she did but she stepped
forward as the widow of the founding
chairman of McDonald's pledged this
money and very controversial he said
that she had such enormous compassion
for the widow of the gunman and her two
children that the first payout was going
to go to them and the community went
wild because at first they went wild
that this woman was so benevolent and
then many people went wild with the idea
that the compassion was extended toward
the man who perpetrated this violence
but I think that said a lot about Joan
and Joan even went so far as to go meet
this woman
etna Huberty was her name to console her
I think that says a lot about her that
she was able at that time when she could
have been most concerned about this
family business so to speak that she was
not in crisis management for the family
business but she was concerned about
this woman who's of course life was
ruined and that was really the first of
well they sound relatively small today
they were not at that time of these
donations that she would make that
somehow seemed inexplicable at the time
because they there was there seemed to
be really no rhyme nor reason no pattern
to the giving so tell us about that and
how people would benefit from her
largesse just like that yeah you know
when I first told my agent that I wanted
to write this book
he said philanthropy is so boring I'll
probably hate me for saying so
anthropocentric Allah philanthropist and
there's nothing wrong with people who
write big checks to help people that's
my faith
kind of person on earth but Joan was so
different than that she was so
unorthodox and as you say just as Ray
but the San Diego Padres on a lark in
response to a news item he heard in the
car on the way from the airport back
home Joan was a news junkie and she
would see a story or hear his story or
read a story and call up and all of a
sudden give a ton of money to whomever
needed it or she'd meet someone on a
plane the first freestanding hospice in
San Diego began because she met a woman
on a plane who was a doctor who was her
age and Joan was so taken by this woman
who had had this formidable education
and wanted to start a free-standing
hospice and in San Diego back again when
now we take hospice for granted it's a
wonderful thing we all know it's an
incredible an incredible presence in a
community but it wasn't the case then it
was pretty new and so Joan loved this
woman and the next day she got a check
from Joan and Joan worked very hard to
make sure that the land was secured so
that this hospice was built and time and
time again that's how she gave money
flood victims there were flood victims
in Rapid City South Dakota no this was
but there were actually yes you're
worried there first in the 70s there was
a huge flood in Rapid City and then in
1997 there was a devastating flood in
Grand for Grand Forks North Dakota and
sheshe would see the mayor mayor Pat
Owens was this petite mayor she'd just
been elected and she was on TV every
single night discussing the terrible
state you could see the terrible state
of the area on television every night
and Joan was so moved by that that she
had her friends a former mayor Maureen
O'Connor fly into Grand Forks with a
check for twenty million dollars and the
condition was that it go immediately as
immediately as possible to flood victims
to offer them relief and that her name
be kept out of it but of course she
didn't realize that somebody was going
to trace the tale what kind of
yeah and then of course I want to be
sure you have time for some questions so
we get to the big donations that really
set her apart and still do to this day
yeah yeah and I as a public radio
reporter of course had always heard
about Joan Kroc and the gift that she
gave in in 2003 of two hundred and
twenty five million dollars which again
was not whimsical but it was as much
because she related to the then
president of NPR as it was that she was
captivated by the NPR mission which of
course many people are and they loved
and can name every host Joan wasn't like
that she just understood the power and
value of media to a free for democracy
but what I didn't know until I started
researching this book that she gave a
job they gave she gave a gift that was
ten times larger to the Salvation Army
also posthumously that was to build
recreation centers in poor neighborhoods
all around the country she'd built one
before she died in San Diego at the cost
of eighty million dollars and it was so
beautiful and so transformative for the
neighborhood that that was where she
left the lion's share of her fortune
when she died and of course the
Salvation Army wasn't equipped to do
this it was a very difficult gift for
them because there weren't in the
business of building world-class
recreation centers but they prayed and
they decided to accept the money and
that amount was close I think by the
time it cashed out it was close to two
billion dollars one since I mean that's
an amazing sum even by today's standards
so the largest gift ever I think and if
you had to sum up Joan and the way you
feel about her having spent so much time
studying her talking to family and
people who knew her what would you say
your biggest impression is and was about
her you know Cynthia she lived life to
the fullest and even when she was
diagnosed with a terminal illness and
her family of course was devastated she
said I've lived an amazing life and I I
don't know I'm sure everyone here has
the same feeling how do I give my life
meaning
and how do I especially as you get older
how do you feel like you're useful in
the world and Joan was useful in so many
different ways grand and small and while
most of us of course don't have that
kind of resource what I love is that she
was just so so big in everything that
she did on the way she gambled she
smoked a lot
she bought incredible jewels which she
gave away but she also had the biggest
heart so I think that those are the
things that stick with me is that she
was not afraid she was unafraid or at
least if she was it doesn't seem like
anybody around her knew it and I find
that those are qualities that I hope to
mimic in my own life especially as I get
older and the story of her almost define
her husband in a way she did a lot of
things that maybe her husband would not
have been so excited about a lot of the
gifts were not things that he
necessarily would have supported and I
don't think she did that to annoy him I
think she just worked from the heart and
from compassion and what better story
can there be
she truly lived life she lived like she
lived life yeah I think we all know a
lot more about ray and Joan Kroc than
when we walked in here don't you think
hope so Lisa that was excellent
and I know now some of you have
questions and might need to fill in the
gap here or - or or just have something
that you don't like to ask Lisa so who
would like to go first just raise your
hand and and we will call on you don't
be shy now we're all friends here here
we go right here and please speak up if
you would my wife and I grew up in the
Midwest in the Chicago area through that
time period and we find it so
fascinating the story and all the
relativity and we really appreciate the
two of you and the actors came to bring
it out I was just wondering if you think
a lot of foundations with marijuana
becoming such a mainstream concept in
this time meaning a lot of foundations
will get involved in people like Al Anam
at the back end of that whole thing
that's really interesting yeah you know
I have no idea I live in California of
course where now they've just legalized
marijuana and it's controversial in so
many ways I don't know I do know that
Joan was aware of and became friendly
with Betty Ford and she was also an
early supporter of Hazelden which being
from the Midwest you may know is
headquartered and outside of Minneapolis
and those two forces have united in
recent years so and there are big
pavilions in each place that are that
were supported by joan years ago so i
can only imagine that that's
unfortunately a big business to be
involved in right now and will only get
bigger yeah yeah maybe should we should
we point out the oxford exchange yes in
fact I was just going to say if you if
you don't mind standing
Blake Casper and his sister Allison
Casper Adams are here today yay Fanny
they are
they are the grandchildren of Fritz
Kasper who started the McDonald's Empire
here in the Bay Area the very first
McDonald's is still there down at
believe it's 35 15 South dale mabry i
think i got that address right and it
was also Blake and Alison who their
company built this amazing building that
lease has been talking about call the
Oxford exchange and so it's this is sort
of the place that McDonald's built I
think you could say that
and but it's quite different in that
it's a bookstore
coffee tea lunch and you walk in here
and you just leave your cares at the
door it's you think so beautiful that
people get married here its spectacle
than I thought when I came here and I
was so grateful for the invitation and
the stories ever since this book came
out and when I got this invitation I was
I've learned so many fantastic cascading
effects of McDonald's in different
places and this certainly is a shining
there's nothing like it I've never been
I've been in hundreds of bookstores I've
never seen anything like this before so
you think really likes it I think she
likes it the two of you of the
conversation bring any questions for
Blake laughs Lisa baby Chu Martina
yes yeah so even before McDonald's came
along in rake rocks life Ray had a woman
who was his gal Friday I don't think
anybody calls themselves that anymore
but most of us probably know soju
Martina was raised gal Friday at the at
his core business Prince Castle sales
where they sold these milkshake machines
and she was a larger-than-life
personality too she was fearless she was
in bad financial shape when she walked
in and ray hired her and he was so taken
with her he hired her on the spot and
she was with him for years and years and
she in fact gave him the first hundred
bucks I think it was when he went to
incorporate McDonald's as a core
business separate from the franchising
that the brothers had so she was so
instrumental that he gave her 10% of
McDonald's stock and when McDonald's
went public in 1965 she became I think
it was five or six million dollars on
paper instantly and there were all kinds
of great newspaper articles written
about her because at the time the idea
that a woman was she was elevated to
treasure that she was such an executive
she became an executive and a
corporation and that she was so
incredibly wealthy but what I love about
her so that was incredibly unusual she
was she apparently wore turbans and was
very elegant and and believed in
mystical things but what I was so cool
about her is that when Ray and Harry
sonna born the fellow I described who
came up with the franchise formula that
and who was the president of McDonald's
and took McDonald's public when Ray and
Harry were at odds there was big
friction in the company of course and
June was called unofficially the
vice-president of equilibrium and
everybody would go to her because they
knew you know maybe suck having mom and
dad fighting that was sort of the the
ethos there and she was stant you know
very staid and in the middle and would
help anyone she took people in when they
had problems when they got divorces she
was an incredible person I wish I could
find out more about her there is a
site that her family built when she
passed away but she stayed on the board
of McDonald's I think until her death
she was very instrumental in Ronald
McDonald House and she built herself a
beautiful property down in Palm Beach
when she left
McDonald's up in Chicago's so it's
interesting that a company that was not
favorable to women in the early days had
an integral piece of history was was
told by her presence there you were it
you you did not meet her you say or you
did it just on a different note the
reviews that have come out on your book
and there was one in the Wall Street
Journal just last week can you talk
about those reviews and you just talk
about kind of the broader picture where
the founder coming out in December and
kind of all the different kind of angles
that are being you know kind of used
with McDuff
sure yeah it's kind of funny all of a
sudden McDonald's which never went away
is being sort of venerated in pop
culture with Michael Keaton playing Ray
Kroc and this movie that's coming out
any minute and laura dern plays the
first wife it's a great cast you know
it's strange I got interested in this
because of both the NPR connection
wondering who is this woman who
basically helped save NPR's finances but
also because I covered this piece
sculpture in Santa Monica where I was
until recently an arts reporter and this
giant nuclear mushroom cloud sculpture
was I was told built by Joan Kroc and it
was in disarray they weren't sure how
they were gonna fix it or save it and I
thought well why would Joan Kroc build
this very unusual or fund this unusual
sculpture and it turns out that she was
a major no nukes proponent in the 80s
and a funder in many many different ways
of the movement and that's what got me
interested in it the movie I think it's
just coincidental that I think they were
looking for something that was like the
the social network at least that's what
I've read and and I think it's just
strange coincidence that
the writer of the film and I both have
been rooting around reading these old
books there only there are very few
books that were written about the early
days of McDonald's one was Ray's memoir
from 1977 and one was from 1986 which
was a really excellent corporate history
so I don't know if it's just that now
we're getting old enough that we're
interested in things that are nostalgic
for our lives or childhoods or it's just
it's it's interesting but great it's
it's a fascinating time it'll be
interesting to see how people respond to
the movie apparently Ray Kroc is studied
in business schools all around the world
even today and the franchise model of
course is studied so we'll see what
happens but yeah I've been enjoying
really fortunate press it's a good story
it's a good story it's sort of like we
think why c-span's here today that was
surprised we were very happy it's very
happy surprised yet and the synergy of
having the movie come out with the book
just having launched you know it's great
because I think I think you know just
from the trailer I've seen Michael
Keaton's going to bring a whole new
energy and perspective to Ray Kroc the
man that may be a little different than
what you know you are able to see in the
book so well it's also important to
point out that my publisher is brilliant
because they knew that the movie was
coming out and so exactly
shout out to Dutton and Jill Schwartzman
thank you yeah that doesn't hurt yes yes
this does anyone else have a question
for Lisa there you go away yours back
most great companies the key to success
is who they surround themselves with and
you pointed out some great people of
course what about Fred Fred Terry how
did how does he play in a relationship
and was he there were there some
exchanges that you
identified in a book yes Fred Turner
unfortunately I didn't get to talk to
him before he passed away he would not
talk to me but Fred Turner was Ray's
hand-picked successor and he after ray
retired became the chairman of
McDonald's and was integral even before
that as a young man he was apparently
there the night that Ray walked into the
criterion restaurant and first laid eyes
on Joan he talks about it one of the
documentaries that was made about
McDonald's so he what an amazing force
he was he was literally at the griddle
so like Joan he worked at the
restaurants and knew intimately how
things worked behind the scenes in a
McDonald's and was entrusted by Ray
groomed by Ray to take over and he did
and he served for many years he was also
very important to point out an
instrumental in getting Ronald McDonald
House which most of you probably know
does incredible work with sick children
and their families he's the one who in
1977 when ray turned 75 decided to help
take this idea which had started in
Philadelphia as a result of one
franchise he had kind of grown out of a
need in that community it's a longer
story than that but that was one
franchise that did it and Fred
identified that for Ray's 75th birthday
what do you get the man who has
everything he asked people to donate to
a fund which allowed other McDonald's to
get involved and start their own local
Ronald McDonald's houses so yeah he's
he's also a whole book unto himself and
a critical force in the early early days
for sure right here there's a long
record of America
become wealthy and then donate a good
amount of money in Rockefeller and more
recently like gates and Buffett
yes that's contextualized shown in that
in those circles right now was she was
she influential was she typical or in
line with what people have done in the
past so glad that you asked that one of
the reasons I wrote this book and kept
at it when I hit walls which I did
almost constantly especially because
McDonald's did not wish to help me in my
research I and and Jones family was
reluctant to talk to me - one of the
reasons I kept at it is because in in
looking at Jones philanthropy I realized
that she gave away all of her money
before bill gates and Buffett were
heralded for making their pledge to give
away all their money
she was very unorthodox in the sense
that in in the late in the early 90s she
got tired of running a foundation for
anybody here who knows about foundations
it's very complicated understandably so
she shut her foundation down in 1991 and
basically just started giving out of her
checkbook she was rich enough that she
didn't need that big corporate structure
so I think that that's very interesting
it's it's not something that works for
everyone
or would work for everyone but she
didn't want to have to answer to all of
the when you get all these requests you
have to handle all the appeals and when
you the more you give money the more
people ask for money and it wasn't that
she was trying to skirt any sort of
regulation she just wanted privacy and
she just wanted to be able to give so
there were people in her life who
thought that that was unwise that if she
had kept the Joan B Kroc foundation in
place at the time of her death it would
last in perpetuity were it funded and
managed correctly like the foundations
that you mentioned but she made the
choice not to do that she didn't really
feel the need to have a foundation that
lasted forever she didn't necessarily
know that there were people she would
trust even though of course whoever runs
the Ford Foundation had nothing to do
with the Ford family in its origin so
it's a really interesting story I think
for people who are involved in any sort
of philanthropy because what she did was
not right for everyone but what she did
was definitely right for her and
pioneering and in many ways selfless
there are people who have taken that
giving pledge that gates and Buffett
have taken to give away half or more of
their wealth who aren't wealthy and I
love that I love the people who aren't
enormous ly wealthy make that commitment
and I love that Joan made that
commitment too but didn't do it with any
sort of Proclamation she just it just
happens to be what happened so I hope
that answers your question but it's a
fascinating glimpse into American
philanthropy for sure that I hope
celebrates her for a long time to come
and this was five years of your life to
research this and write this book yes
that's this big hunk of time so was this
like a labor of love and a way for you
to do this I always say I got a PhD and
Ray and job without never as my
long-term partner pointed out I've never
done anything for as long as I have this
book which is telling about me I'm sure
well we hope you've enjoyed Lisa Napoli
the author of Ray and Joan the man who
made the McDonald's fortune and the
woman who gave it all away I feel like
we know them so much better after this
conversation today and it has been
wonderful thank you saying thank you so
much appreciate everyone being here
[Applause]
and if there are any other questions I'm
happy to answer them of course yes yes I
just needed to retake sure